i was not ready i was not emotionally
prepared the dead speak a huge huge
moment
at the end of the season two premiere of
the mandalorian and we're gonna be
talking about all the big moments from
the episode but
definitely that one from season two
episode one aka
chapter nine the marshall i'm ash
crosston and i think it goes without
saying but
spoilers to follow
[Music]
it would be really hypocritical for the
guy that helped bring darth maul back to
life after got cut in half for me to say
that
somebody can't survive a sarlacc pip so
let's recap a little bit and then we'll
get to the big moment but
we pick things back up with mando and
baby yoda and yes that's what i will
continue to call them probably till my
death amanda wants to get baby yoda back
to
his kind so he wants to find the other
mandalorians to help guide him but he
doesn't know where any of them are and
he gets a hot tip that there's one on
tatooine
in this town called mos pelgo and if
you've been following
theories casting rumors reddit maybe you
read the aftermath series then
things are starting to to come together
in your head a little bit because moss
pelgo is a reference to
freetown which is a town in
chuck wendig's aftermath series which
has a character called coban for to come
on that so mando gets to moss pogo
finds this marshall and he's wearing
boba fett's armor and it actually kind
of cracked me up because
he's just i don't know he's just wearing
another shirt it kind of looks a little
dorky at first but
he takes off his helmet and it's
timothy oliphant
timothy olympian introduces himself as
cobb vance and
boy do i not hate the sight of goddamn
timothy olyphant in star wars is the
greatest thing to happen to us in this
the year
of 2020.
do i have to say it should i say it
it's daddy it's it's a it's a daddy that
felt good
so wearing the mandalorian armor betrays
the creed if you're not a mandalorian so
mando is like
i want that armor codman says absolutely
not and they're like
let's duel like hamilton and burn i
gotta stop watching hamilton
so they go outside they go to duel and
what happens what always
happens when you go to duel a giant
sand dragon pops up and interrupts you
you're like
again every time so this is a crate
dragon and we've seen
the skeleton in a new hope but this is a
creature that has popped up in a lot of
video games and other places it's a fun
little easter egg
so they team up despite their
differences and this season we get to
see
the redemption arc of the tuscan raider
it's beautiful
so a big battle ensues to defeat the
crate dragon
and boom boom bop lot of things and
mando is swallowed up at one point and
he explodes out of it into victory
yay and this is the point where i'm like
if he can do this
maybe just maybe this is how
boba fett escaped the sarlacc pit
i don't know just a theory so they're
victorious and cobanth is like
here's your armor i hope you cross pass
again and boy do i hope they cross
path again and i'm saying so we get to
the end of the episode and this is what
we really want to talk about right
so the aspect ratio changes and we see
the twin suns and i'm like oh that's
[Music]
beautiful
yes that is tamira morrison
that's boba fett that is i feel like i
have to do my due diligence here
even though i don't think any of us
think this tamira morrison
play jenga fat whose dna was used to
make
the clones and boba fett lots of
people had or have this face
so there is a sliver of a possibility
that this is somebody else i don't think
so i just feel like i legally
not legally at all but i feel like i
just have to say it just to
cya you know what that means means cover
your a
but this means so many things there are
so many untold stories untold moments
how this happened where has he been what
has he been
up to how's he feeling does he want his
armor back so you saw the beginning of
the video a little
dave filoni from the premiere last year
i asked him straight up
do you think boba fett could have
survived the sarlacc pit and his answer
his answer was interesting
is that boba fetter what's going on
interesting interesting yeah
interesting do you think there's a
possibility he survived the sarlacc
interesting interesting interesting i
mean there's always possibilities i
don't like to limit our storytelling in
any way
and you know who knows i've been
surprised it would be really
hypocritical for the guy that helped
bring darth maul back to life after got
cut in half for me to say that
somebody can't survive a sarlacc pit but
i don't know you know i mean
anything's possible in star wars and i
always think when fans love something
that's what really fuels the possibility
and the believability so
who knows i love dave dave i love you
that was so many interestings
that i i have my conclusion you know
what i'm saying
how do you feel how are you feeling
oh oh okay well
that's that's one theory about boba fett
but i wanna know yours
that's gonna be this week's uh recap of
the mandalorian if you like this video
and you want me to do this every week
just let me know send me a tweet that's
the best way to contact me like even
better than a
text honestly addicting but there were
loads of easter eggs in this episode
some things i didn't even get to and
didn't even get to mention so
let me know your favorite or thing you
noticed in this episode that i didn't
even mention
and um may the force be with you maybe
we'll do this again bye guys